welcome everyone i'm really glad to see
everybody here in luce hall as well as
virtually via zoom to our very special
talk this afternoon so my name is
stephen wilkinson i'm the militant
professor of indian south asian studies
here at yale and the faculty director of
the macmillan center
so the macmillan center is
yale's focal point for the study of
cultures societies languages
around the world we train our students
to understand the world to understand
the world's languages
we send them out in the world to learn
and we also have the opportunity to
bring distinguished visitors here to
yale
so that we may learn from them
here
now i'm really delighted
today to introduce our featured speaker
the mayor of warsaw rafael
scoffsi
and our moderator professor marshy shaw
who is also the director of graduate
studies for our very active european and
russian studies and a program at the
european studies council and marcy
organized this event so mayor
czeskowski's title for today's talk is
war in ukraine and a new transatlantic
agenda
this event is being supported by the
george herbert walker jr lecture fund in
international studies here at the little
macmillan center so this was a fund
established in honor of bert walker
um
by the walker family um
the walker family has produced both a
uh
both bush presidents
who were yale graduates are a part of
that family so i'm about to note that
the mayor is delivering one of our first
in-person walker lectures since 2019.
mayor schuster has been the mayor of
warsaw since 2018 he's a member of the
european committee of regions and the
board of euros cities in 2020 he was the
civic platform's candidate for the
presidency of poland
he is a former member of the european
parliament vice chair of the european
people's party and in 2014 he served as
the deputy minister of foreign affairs
of the republic of poland and in 2013 as
a minister for administration and
digitization in the cabinet of the
former prime minister of poland donald
tusk
mayor schaskowski was born in warsaw
where he studied and graduated from the
university of warsaw in 2004 he attended
his phd degree in political science he
speaks fluent english french spanish
russian and italian and moderating his
talk today
is uh professor marcy shore professor
shaw teaches modern european
intellectual history here at yale
her research focuses on the intellectual
history of 20th and 21st century central
and eastern europe she has written many
things she's the translator of mikhail
glovinski's the black seasons the author
of caviar and ashes a warsaw
generation's life and death and marxism
1918 1968
the taste of ashes the afterlife of
totalitarianism in eastern europe and
the ukrainian night an intimate history
of
revolution she was also in 2018 a
recipient of a very prestigious
guggenheim fellowship for her current uh
book project
so thank you to marcy for moderating
today's talk uh the format today is
going to be this we're going to hear
from mayor shostakovsky first and then
professor shaw and mayor schwarzkovsky
will sit up front for a discussion on a
q a session uh that will give people the
opportunity to uh ask them whatever you
like uh thank you both and thank you all
for joining us this afternoon
[Applause]
[Music]
yes hello
uh good afternoon gene w it is a
honor and a privilege to be here at yale
and uh have an opportunity to talk to
you about what's happening uh right now
in my
country and in my region of course and
to talk about uh
about the uh transatlantic relationship
and of course what kind of impact the
situation of today has on on
transatlantic relations i mean first of
all i i have to tell you that as it was
mentioned before uh i started uh
in european policy and i was uh i was a
think tanker for quite a long time and a
university lecturer and i still am
uh at boys university uh dealing mostly
with the european affairs
and i worked in the european parliament
that was a member of the european
parliament that was the minister of
european integration and then i moved
into national politics
some people say one of the biggest
mistakes of my life
and
and i was i was a minister and then i
was a member of of national parliament
and then i moved to local government
this is pretty unusual because usually
it's the other way around you know you
start with local government then you do
national then maybe european later on
and of course everyone was telling me
listen i mean finally that's a job of
your life because you can focus on the
future
you can actually start building and
modernizing your city and of course
everything you do
will leave an impact because that's
that's what happens when you're a mayor
of a wonderful city and warsaw of course
is a wonderful city and you will just
focus on
on on modernizing your city and and on
top of that
you will not be subjected to the
political bickering and and partisanship
because people will just simply
you know national media will forget
about you for a while and only when
there is a small crisis maybe they will
be reminded of you
uh and i thought yeah well
it's worth a try and of course you know
i'm
born and bred in warsaw so so of course
that was quite a challenge
after i became mayor boom you know a
sewer pipe burst under the whistler
river so
and by the way it burst twice
uh so of course i was i was mostly folk
focusing my attentions to that and with
uh with the crazy uh government in place
and with the propaganda that they've
unleashed it was not easy
and then when we just got after you know
after the crisis of the first crisis
when he got out of that
of course covet hit us
four waves of it and just as we were
getting out of it
a war happened
which obviously uh gives you quite a
perspective and uh and sometimes i
introduce myself as uh not as a mayor of
warsaw but as a minister of crisis
situations because all the time you have
to deal with the crisis but that's
politics for you
politics of today
but of course what happens in in in
ukraine today
uh is uh incredibly serious and it has
huge implications for the security of of
of the region but also for the security
of the world
and that's why we need to seriously talk
about that
and the thing is that you know we were
warning our friends
in europe and also in america for years
and uh we were observing of vladimir
putin's career and for us at least it
was pretty clear who are we dealing with
so we were not misled even you know at
the beginning of the century that this
guy could be a good democrat because it
was just enough to study his days
in kgb to study his days in petersburg
to sort of guess what kind of people are
really what kind of guy we're dealing
with
and we were telling our friends in
europe and we were telling our friends
in america you know don't do deals with
thugs
or at least
think about security
think about making poland and making
europe more
independent from fossil fuels coming
from russia
think about
putting your energy into
any democratic
endeavor you can which is going to
strengthen our
our neighbors
to the east of poland to the so-called
post-soviet sphere because our ukrainian
friends our moldovan friends the
beginning even our fellow russian
friends
were striving towards democracy
and of course you know everyone was in
the us but sometimes even in europe
everyone was sort of lumping us together
as eastern europeans and thinking that
we are no different well we are because
of course we have quite
different democratic experiences
but we all wanted the same thing we
wanted to be peaceful stable democratic
nations
and by the way ukraine was promised that
when it decided to give its nuclear
weapons away it was guaranteed
by
the western powers that the integrity
and sovereignty of ukraine will be
protected
and later on you know we were trying all
the time to convince our friends in
europe and in the us that we should at
least
buy that security build an energy union
i will explain in a second what it is
built a strong eastern policy of the
european union
i remember i started working in the
european parliament in 2004 just when
orange revolution hit and everyone was
hyped up you know for a while
and then we said okay now is the moment
to build the energy union
and in a few months i mean you know the
attention waned and people started
thinking about something different and
again
we've heard the same spiel
come on you're obsessed with russia i
mean you know there's such reliable
partners even in the soviet times when
it came to gas when it came to oil we
could rely on them and we could do
business with them and now
with new russia why not
and many people are saying if you are
investing in the future of ukraine
investing in the future of moldova
trying to promise the european union
membership not mentioning any security
guarantees
then you are actually undermining the
security of europe and you are saying
you are dealing with thugs you are
dealing with guys who just understand
the language of power and all the time
we've heard
you're obsessed you don't understand the
modernity because you're just you know
there in eastern europe not seeing the
bigger picture
but fortunately we were able to prepare
ourselves at least a bit for what was to
come
look at energy union
it was an idea of donald tusk our former
prime minister
uh it was supported of course by our
politician it was realized by our
governments
also when i was minister of european
affairs and before we were doing quite a
lot in the european parliament and what
we did for example we
made steps to make sure that we would be
building lg terminals so that we could
import gas what we did we did we did
inverse flow okay and the so-called
interconnectors which means that just
what 10 years ago 15 years ago gas and
oil could just flow one way from russia
to europe now we can do the reverse we
started building into connectors with
the baltic
with the baltic states
with slovakia the czech republic and so
on and so forth so that we could
transport oil and gas throughout europe
we also
invested in big reservoirs of gas and
now it's an obligation
to have those reservoirs for at least
three months
and we've also strengthened the
competition policy of the european union
so that you can go after gasprom when it
is breaking the rules of competition
we've decoupled
uh two very important things one is
extraction of oil and then the
distribution of oil and gas right so at
least because of our insistence we're
better prepared
to to what's happening i mean as you
know just yesterday russia cut gus
gas from from from
to poland and to bulgaria
and similarly and simultaneously we were
strengthening the eastern dimension of
the european union investing a lot in
those links with our friends
uh to the east
and it was tough boy it was tough and i
remember you know talking to our friends
negotiating it and of course so many
hurdles on the way and if you mentioned
uh north stream one north seam true two
the pipeline gas
pipe under the baltic sea we were
warning our friends listen don't get
too much dependent on on russia and
again you know our arguments were not
heard by our german friends and they
were telling us it's a business
enterprise you know you shouldn't be so
insistent
and then what and then of course
history proved us right and of course
this is a very bitter
pill to swallow
and now we have
a crisis on our on our hands in a crisis
of global dimensions
what happens is that of course putin has
miscalculated because he thought first
of all that he would be able to divide
the ukrainian society he thought that
the ukraine society will be divided that
many
troops will desert that his army will be
able to actually take over kiev in a few
days he thought that he's going to
divide us because he was remembering
2014 when we've agreed on sanctions but
they were not very serious and again i
was negotiated negotiating them and when
we were telling our friends god you know
these sanctions need to be serious we
need to go after the oligarchs we need
to do something about gas and oil again
they were saying no no no no
you know step by step
and of course putin thought that you
know with such a weak response
to russian aggression in 2014 he thought
that he could do it again
and that's what his intelligence was
telling him
so the incredible thing is that of
course he miscalculated when it comes to
ukraine because it turned out that
we have a united response and by the way
i was just four or five days before the
war i was in kiev and even there people
were telling me yeah well maybe 20 30
percent of ukrainian troops will desert
or maybe they will not
listen to orders there will be two or
three important regional leaders who
might desert nothing of the sort
happened
and the uk the ukrainians really did
their lesson i mean we've got no time to
go into the
military uh
aspects of it but really i mean after
2014 they've learned their lesson i mean
my favorite thing is that there's an app
if you are
a citizen of ukraine you have that app
which is used to communicate with your
government and now it was turned into an
app on which you can inform about
russian troop movements
make pictures maps and so on and send it
directly to the authorities and no one
can fake it because if you don't have a
ukrainian identity you can't operate
that and the russians you know they were
supposed to have brilliant communication
devices after the georgian war now of
course they're using cell phones
because putin has created a kleptocracy
and these guys were just stealing from
government
they were not investing in in modern
equipment and they're fantastic at doing
a little mischief
and hybrid warfare but and
tactical movement but it turned out that
they're not that good at strategy thanks
god
so that's the lesson we're learning and
of course we should be learning more
now he has also miscalculated when it
comes to us but most importantly his
miscalculated when it comes
to
the civil society and the power of the
social media because i mean you know
this this fight that we're observing is
epic
and it's so clear it's like david and
goliath it's of biblical proportions and
it's so clear who's a good guy who's a
bad guy i'm sometimes comparing it for
my american audience to
to your pop culture you know you have
like this
marvel comic ultimate evil
fighting this this every
american every man who suddenly turns
into a hero okay it's so clear and
that's why the response of the civil
society the response
of all of us was so clear and so strong
and the pressure exerted on elected
leaders was so strong if someone were to
tell me two months ago that so many
american companies would go out of
russia so many german european companies
would go out of russia
i wouldn't have believed
hadn't i seen it
but of course that's also because of the
pressure of the civil society and here
again putin has miscalculated because he
doesn't understand it
and again it brings us to to to the same
to the same
uh thesis that you know this this fight
is so clear in 2014 it wasn't so clear
or we didn't tell the story well the
narrative was a bit different
and he is miscalculated when it comes to
our response because finally
the european union the united states of
america started responding in a
concerted and in a tough way
because these sanctions bite
for the first time we went after the
oligarchs for the first time we were
talking about
getting ourselves seriously independent
uh
when it comes to russian fossil fuels
and we are taking some tough decisions
can we do more yes we can
those sanctions can be even tougher but
you know
swift
oil and
gas american european companies out of
out of russia that's that's huge
and and of course you know you can
always think about whether the glass is
half full of half empty but
i think that it was pretty surprising
for for putin and of course we need to
do more
and the important thing is that we have
to persevere and the important thing is
that
we cannot simply think that it's going
to uh uh to end soon and that then we
can relent
and of course we are facing one of the
biggest refugee crisis in history
in europe but also in the world
after the second world war
you know that
just three months ago poland was 120th
when it came to accepting refugees some
people said 105th because you know there
are different statistics
now we are second soon to be first
that shows you the magnitude of the
problem if you remember the
mediterranean crisis when europe was
panicking you know barbed wire and so on
and people running amok not knowing how
to respond
we had 200 000 people at a peak 200 000
people coming to europe
we have 300 000 people who came to
warsaw alone
in a matter of month over a month
so that shows you the magnitude of the
problem and of course the refugees are
vulnerable people by definition but we
have the most vulnerable because these
are
usually mostly young women with kids
i have 120 000 kids in in warsaw
i have 280 000 kids in my schools
and because we have granted courageously
we've granted ukrainians citizen-like
status they have access to free
education to free
health care and to free social
protection
that means that we should be accepting
120 000 kids to our schools we have
enrolled already 20 000
and now we come to
the most important part of
my message to you
is that what we should do without with
it i mean the most important thing is
there is no strategy guys
there is no strategy on the polish level
there is no strategy on a european level
there's no strategy on an international
level
most of what you see is is improvisation
most of what you see is not a miraculous
government
central government dealing with it it's
the people
the people have accepted ukrainians to
their homes
most of us in poland you don't see i
mean people come from from the us from
from europe from different places
specialists in migration and you know
they're amazed they say okay where are
the the refugees
because there are no refugee camps huge
refugee camps there are no
pitch tents in in in
in in parks there are no people on the
streets because they're at our homes but
of course the solidarity
which is amazing
cannot be
kept without a strategy for for for
months and years because you know people
accepted ukrainians for two three four
months
but not for for eight or nine of course
some of them most of them stay with
their friends and with their family so
they can because we had a huge ukrainian
diaspora in poland before that but some
of them you know stay with complete
strangers so we need a strategy we need
a relocation scheme
in europe
where it will be coordinated by the
european union where different countries
make pledges and then someone needs to
coordinate it because a month ago i was
calling in the middle of the night i was
calling different mayors from poland and
from europe and telling them please you
know take 300 take 200 guys send us a
few buses because we were overwhelmed
and this government is not asking for a
strategy and it is not
authorizing the european union to work
because of course they want to you know
get all the political credit
and i keep telling them guys you know no
government
will be able to deal with such a crisis
and of course that's why we need a push
from the americans from our european
friends
in order to
have a strategy because we have lots of
u.n agencies working on the ground we
have european agencies working on the
ground but that's haphazard it's
piecemeal you know because the
government is just picking this service
you know this help and so on we are
having our own
strategy in warsaw but that's not enough
because you know if i have a strategy
about education
i told the minister of education guys
you know we cannot accept 120 000 kids
overnight we need most of them should do
distant learning
on a ukrainian platform and that's what
the ukrainian education ministry wants
right that makes more sense but there is
no strategy so we are doing it ourselves
in warsaw we are enrolling people to our
schools but we're also building those
places in which they can learn online
we're getting equipment from donors and
so on
but of course because warsaw is also the
only city in poland which has preschools
for free because that was part of my
electoral program
that creates a huge pull factor
and again without a strategy it's going
to be very difficult to deal with that
so strategy strategy strategy both on a
national and a european level we have
done a lot in the european union to
regulate the status of refugees
but these guys according to the european
law are not refugees they're displaced
people
in need of temporary protection
different directive supply
so again i'm going to give you an
example if you're a refugee and if you
get registered in poland if you go to
germany then you lose
any social protection because the
european union wants to fight with
secondary movements and with the
possibility to choose the country of
your asylum because that would mean that
everyone would go to germany or to
sweden because that's where the
conditions are best
but these guys
again are not refugees so for example
they ask me
if i register do i lose my social rights
if then i go to the netherlands or to
germany and i cannot answer them because
we don't have a one system in europe on
that so that's why we need a european
strategy
and i could go on and on and give you
some other examples of that and of
course when it comes to support
we need that support not only to go to
the central government but we need that
support to go to the non-governmental
organizations by the way exactly the
same non-governmental organizations that
now save our day
were the ones that were deprived of
financing by the populist government
those who help with refugees those who
help with women's rights children
trafficking
lgbtq community and so on and so forth
those are the guys who are now
helping us and now are
saving the day so the money should go to
refugees to non-governmental
organizations and also to us
and that's also the message that i'm
trying to sell in europe and to our
american friends
and now finally in the last few minutes
about geopolitics because you know
everyone is is asking the same questions
what's going to happen we don't know
what's going to happen
and you've heard
because i assume that you're interested
in in what's happening if you're here
you've heard lavrov you heard putin just
yesterday saying that you know they
might escalate
that
uh those those myths that there is a
polish american plot to send our
soldiers into ukraine and so on and so
forth this is really worrying
and of course these guys are threatening
to escalate they're escalating already
in the east
they're threatening to maybe go to
another level but i tell you one thing
i mean
the thugs and bullies
and some some of us know it from our
neighborhood and from our high school
understand only the word of strength of
the the the reality of strength
so we need to sell united we need to
send
clear signals
to russia we shouldn't lose it from
sight because again i'm afraid that
after two three four five months
people will turn their attention to
something different
and of course the end game is very
difficult to foresee
because maybe putin is looking for a
face-saving exercise we don't know but
what if he finds one and then it's
unacceptable to our ukrainian friends
what do we do then
and of course
what do we do with
the crisis which is
at our hands the humanitarian crisis
because we've opened our ukrainian
brothers and sisters and we will keep on
doing so but we probably are going to
have a second wave just three or four
days ago
you know five days ago before coming
here i talked to people from donbass and
he were telling me you know we they were
telling me we were there for seven eight
years in the war zone and we didn't move
but after what we've seen in bucharest
we decided to move
and they are moving to poland so of
course we cannot do it alone we need
assistance and we need help
and of course that has huge implications
for our security
there's always a silver lining
because the the important stuff is also
that you know the
centuries of
historical experiences can be turned
overnight and we can build
a much sounder and better
foundation for our relations with our
ukrainian friends
this is incredibly important for the
stability of the region
and for the chance of those
post-service states to be
integrated into
the european community
but the important thing is
also that
some of them will stay in poland
many of them will go back with
completely different expectations
building a democratic state
i meet them on the ground and you know
at the beginning my and i speak russian
so it's a bit more easy and they look at
me and you know i tell them i'm a mayor
i want to help and so on in russian and
most of them don't believe me a mayor
a railway station with no security
guards speaking to me and everything's
for free we need to ask our ukrainian
volunteers to explain that this is not a
scam
but i don't want to cheat them out out
of their money but these expectations
will be carried back
we hope and that will allow
our ukrainian friends to create a
democratic society in ukraine
so that's
the positive
the positive angle to it
but of course
still this huge geopolitical
is ahead of us and we need to get our
heads together and try to resolve it and
it's not going to be easy
so i'll stop here guys because i know
that you want to
probably ask quite a few questions and
and
marcy as well
so that we can move
fluidly to to the second part
and i always finish all my lectures on
my talks the same way
today and and and and and in this day
and age it's rainy
i have the feeling of a tear in time
that you have a dramatic historical
moment the sense that one world has
ended you know and whatever happens next
we're going to be in another world
um
a couple days before the invasion
started our our friend uh slav of our
cartook i'm sure you know that ukrainian
rock star who spent the semester here at
yale so many of you know him
called and i said slava what is the
atmosphere like in kiev
and he said well marcy
imagine a synthesis
between florida in october 1961 during
the cuban missile crisis
and central europe between
the munich agreement of 1938 the
invasion of poland in 1939 it's
something like that
um
and there was a sense that nobody knew
what was coming but one of the things
that i think ukrainians and poland polls
share
is an understanding that everything is
possible
americans don't have this americans
think their constraints on reality you
know after trump was elected people are
walking around saying okay this is bad
this is very bad but we're going to get
through it we have checks and balances
checks and balances was repeated like a
yoga mantra
whereas east europeans i feel like know
that everything can look normal but it
can turn on a dime and you have to
somehow be prepared for that even if
it's impossible to be prepared
so my my first question is that given
that terran time what has surprised you
most that you would not have been able
to conceive of three months ago
well quite a few things i mean you know
i've just tried to talk about it for
half an hour how surprising it was for
for many of us at the end of the day
because you know we all knew that that
that there's gonna that something is
brewing
and and we were also informed about it
and we we took it seriously but everyone
i talked to
uh five days before the war in kiev was
telling me it's gonna be another hybrid
war for you know
a bit of but no one expected a full-out
war seriously i mean so so that of
course was surprising but what really
surprised me
is is this incredible resilience of the
ukrainian of the ukrainian people
um and you know when they come to war so
they're so proud you know most of them
just want to work and they say we do not
want to rely on anyone we just want to
uh earn our upkeep and this is this is
incredibly uh heartening and and and
amazing
uh but also the the response uh the the
the concerted and uh
and unlike the vocal response of of the
west because of this pressure of the
social media i mean if someone were to
to tell me i told you about it you know
just two months ago that that that that
this pressure would be so so so
important
um i i i wouldn't believe that now the
question of course is is whether that is
going to be continued
and and that's a big question so there
are quite a lot of surprises
uh the polish people didn't surprise me
because after years of this this
populist government was trying to fight
with and threaten everyone with refugees
and threaten everyone with lgbt
community and threaten everyone with all
kinds of minorities because they always
need an enemy i knew that there is this
instinct of solidarity that we have in
our dna
by the way i negotiated as a minister of
european affairs that we would accept 7
000 refugees in the mediterranean crisis
and the the populist government was
telling us that they're going to change
the way we live 7 000 you know
and at the moment 7 000 were crossing
our border in ten minutes
so that also shows you you know the
level of of manipulation
quite a lot of quite a lot of surprises
okay so i'll ask one more
quasi-self-interested question which is
that you know
some of us here like myself among them
you know have been in the role of the
cultural mediators and the translators
trying to explain eastern europe to
americans
and if this were an ordinary situation i
would feel like this is going
extraordinarily well we've never gotten
so much attention the journalists are
asking better and better questions
we're better able to connect our
ukrainian colleagues with american
editors and i'm still asking myself like
what
what could we do better what do you do
you have the impression that there are
things here in america that americans by
and large don't yet understand well
enough
that are crucial that we should be on
point about well again i mean of course
but but but listen i mean
president biden was in in in warsaw uh
where i had a chance and an honor to
show him
the place where we uh register
ukrainians
and you know the strongest words
possible
uh about defending every inch of nato
territory i went to the east on numerous
occasions and you know the patriot
missiles i mean
everywhere you know they're american
soldiers the 82nd but only
everywhere you know i mean the reality
changed so much and uh
and the response of the west and the
response and the interest of the
american society is unbelievable i mean
listen i've seen all my friends keep
asking me calling me i see ukrainian
friends the ukrainian flags on on all
social media i see uh in new york all
the russians some of our and vodka
places turning into ukrainian some of
our and vodka places uh
the behavior of of of of of
celebrities and so on and so forth this
is this is unheard of
and the level of interest
so i'm not sure that we can do more
the important thing is that this is that
we draw a lesson from it okay and that
we translate it into action and then we
explain
that
this is huge ramifications for our
security and by the way not only for for
russia and ukraine because all the thugs
in the world all the dictators are
looking at it
and they're thinking okay i mean you
know the west sometimes can pull pull it
together and they can be tough they can
respond in a uniform fashion
okay maybe being aggressive costs a lot
maybe we we should rethink it i mean
that's that's also the reality of of of
today let's hope
so uh so i guess and you know when i'm
i've seen all the all the uh american
journalists in in warsaw
and and really well informed
i never had so much airtime on american
television in my life
of course
you know and it's not only about me or
of course politicians always talk about
themselves
fortunately in america you're you're
allowed to do that
but
but but it is
there is this window of opportunity to
inform but also to draw conclusions from
okay and to to explain what's what and
to explain that we need to be united
that we need to draw conclusions from it
to offer ukraine a european perspective
seriously
which would have never happened to make
ourselves independent of fossil fuels
coming from russia today i was just
elected for uh
the board
of the convent of mayors
where we fight with climate change
and i say you know we this is the moment
where we should seek for synergies
to save our planet to fight with climate
change to make ourselves independent of
of fossil fuels in general and fossil
fuels coming from russia okay we need a
transition period of course
but because it's not gonna happen
overnight but that should i mean the
pandemic and and the crisis in russia
should push us
all of the decision makers
into making the right decisions
and on top of that that also allows us
you know to see who's who
remember
trump and and and how he cozied up to
some russian politicians
remember salvini le pen
the populist government in poland also
liking those populists who are financed
by russia i mean let's talk conclusions
from it you know some of them did
suddenly you know like
half a year ago we were telling the
populists in poland why why have you
removed all the european flags from your
ministries and their only polish ones
by the way the polish flag is the most
beautiful in the world
but why have you removed
the european ones they're back
all of the european flags are there and
all the nato flags are there good you
know they're learning a lesson i mean so
we should also learn a lesson and this
is this is the thing we should be doing
explaining to the american people
explaining to the europeans guys come on
hello crisis
imagine imagine if trump was president
of the united states now jesus christ
almighty
people are telling me people are asking
me
aren't you afraid and i'm saying if
president zelinski is not panicking i'm
not panicking either
but thanks god
you know we have the leaders we have
imagine le pen won france
you know
so so so i mean we should be drawing
conclusions you know
the electoral process is is not a game
many people dislike mainstream political
parties i understand that
but at the end of the day unfortunately
most of the time
we vote for lesser evil
most of the time
we need to vote with our brain at the
end of the day not only with our heart
so this is something this is the point
we should we should be driving
home and believe in me people understand
it in the u.s
five years ago when i was talking about
problems with democracy there were i i
was seeing it in in my friend's eyes
yeah and this guy from
barbarian east what does he know about
democracy trump was elected and suddenly
my american friends started sending me
you know the attack on the capital and
everyone understands me
and by the way
you know poland should be the strongest
democracy in europe now
we cannot afford a weakest link on our
eastern border
so this is another thing we should
another point we should be driving home
and i i say it in every conversation
that i have in the us
that
now if someone is undermining democracy
if someone is undermining the rule of
law if someone is marginalizing poland
or any other country in the european
union
is doing something against
our most important national interests
because we need to be strong
in poland in hungary in slovenia in
france but also of course in the united
states of america
so again maybe i'm just
you know
an optimist
but but but we also have to think about
drawing conclusions from that
let's take some questions from the
audience
senia
i think jenny is also taking questions
from yeah
because you know i'm a politician i love
to talk like my boss
i will hijack agenda here i'm from
ukraine from eastern ukraine and uh
first of all thank you uh i have friends
um also in boston krakow and poznan uh
and residing right now
and um more friends fighting of course
um
and
thanks for the standing so it's also
very important just a few minutes ago
um a u.s house representative voted for
to support landladys
so like with the
landslide first 17 support which is
great
and
you were talking about the
uh well basically some of some of the
side of what u.s actually doing right
now is
uh security security for europe security
for energy right now which is like
another sort of terrorism right now
happening from the russian side
um but
is there is there like a core idea for
the strategy the strategy of security in
europe because you have
germany as incapacitated as a united
nations security council um
and you have few other countries which
are
well uh like hungary and austria which
are behaving like that nothing happens
and uh is there is there like a core one
single idea
outline for this strategy to build
security both physical and
and on energy side
um yeah and i will come later with the
more people asking about border crisis
from belarus um it's
um
yeah and
some part of my question is also like
how to deter crisis from russian side
but i don't think that's uh this is like
very broad question so this is just
about uh also about security preventing
the future crisis because russia is not
going anywhere
well i i'll try to be telegraphic
because there are as if you know three
parts in your question so
first of all i'll i'll i'll start with
the uh with with belarus and so on and
so forth guy because i've been asking
i've been asked that question quite a
lot
on american media as well what changed
right
first of all we have a populist
government right uh
my government when i was minister we
were participating in
uh european solidarity when it came to
refugees we were able to accept refugees
what we just didn't like was a
mathematical formula to distribute
refugees according to quotas because we
thought it was a bad idea and it was a
bad idea because politically you cannot
simply say you know stand in front of
your people and say how many refugees
will you accept i don't know there is
this magical formula invented by the
european commission maybe twenty
thousand maybe fifty thousand that's
that's that's a no-go
uh and don't start it but we were we
were there building policy we we were
at a high table negotiating and so on
and so forth that changed okay and of
course as i told you the populists
always need an enemy
so that was that that was their response
to the mediterranean crisis
now
the belarusian crisis and the border was
different because it was mostly
engineered by putin and by lukashenka
who wanted to destabilize poland
he wanted to destabilize europe but of
course again the populist government
wanted to play a card and wanted to to
have a political win out of that so
that's why
they started building a wall they
started you know
behaving in a in a way which which meant
that they weren't even helping
children
who were dying in the woods
uh but of course now the situation is
completely different because everyone
understands that ukrainians fight also
for our freedom and and for the first
time in years there is a bipartisan
agreement that we need to help and here
on the most part we are on the same page
with the government okay
it doesn't mean that the belarussian
problem
cease to exist
because by the way eight percent of all
the three million who came to poland are
non-ukrainian and it's a hot potato for
the government okay
and by the way when ukrainians go to uh
germany they're all
welcomed but if
there's someone with a nigerian or a
syrian passport they're turned back to
poland
which also is a problem secondly when it
comes to to to your question about
divisions and so on and so forth yes
there are divisions true
but i mean again if someone were to tell
me uh three or four weeks ago or months
ago
that lethal weapons would be provided
for ukrainians by everyone
including the germans okay after months
of organizing and so on and so forth but
at least at least yeah but they've to
i'm not going to defend them okay
i don't want to defend because it's true
that there is no german leadership
at this moment it is true that
the whole
german political class disappointed us
because we were telling them repeatedly
not to the things that they were doing
so i'm not going to defend them but
hopefully they're getting their act
together
by the way because of the greens
which is one of the biggest paradoxes of
history thank you you know i'm thanking
the the german green parties so that
they're courageous and that they know
where they need to adapt their policy
okay
uh but but
of course there are hungarians and we
know them
no one knows viktor orban better than i
do
and of course it is a problem although
at the end of the day they weren't
blocking they haven't blocked a single
decision of the european union the
hungarians
because you know this guy is wonderful
playing different games okay now of
course the question is what comes next
because
we need to start making ourselves
independent of fossil fuels and here the
hungarians say that they will not allow
for that and of course there is this
idea of our some of our
partners that they will start paying
uh putin in rubles okay so are they in
the eurozone or are they in the ruble
zone i don't know that's there was a
tweet of my president uh of my party
donald tusk because it's a pretty apt
question
uh but again i mean it's the pressure
from the people which i hope is going to
to to change it okay
uh and it is changing it so the only
thing is and i'm worried about it how
persistent will we be
whether whether that's not gonna end in
a month or two or three what i'm afraid
is about i'm afraid about the end game
what if putin thinks that you know okay
a part of donbass is enough you know
according to crimea and he stops the war
i'm afraid that then maybe many of our
partners will say oh okay fine great
no it's not going to be great okay but
of course we also need to be realistic
we need to be cautious
but we need to be tough
and if there's an any end game
first we need to
listen to president zelinski okay if
it's a hero he's a hero then listen to
him okay because i'm afraid that in a
few months again there will be a lot of
pressure on zelansky
and i don't want to go back to the minsk
agreements and what kind of implications
it had for the security of europe and
for the future of ukraine which was by
the way forced rammed
down the throat of the ukrainian
government by our german and french
colleagues
okay
but hopefully everyone learns lesson and
at the end of the day seriously
if you were to tell me two or three
weeks two or three months ago what the
response of the west would be
it's still you know it's pretty
surprising that we got our act together
and that we know what we're doing that
we're providing weapons and so on
but of course we need to do more that's
for sure
okay all right
um let's grab a few more yeah yeah let's
take a should we take a few together
yeah okay so let's see let's maximus and
um okay so three of you here
just go guys yeah just go ahead
so uh welcome to good to have you here
man uh my name is max i'm from vilnius
lafayette a little far away you know
from where you come from and you talked
a lot about strategy an important
strategy you clearly are a great fan of
strategy and you still remain the figure
of national politics in poland right
and not only because of presidential
elections before but generally right and
i wonder
in a little bit more than a year from
now you have parliamentary elections in
your country happening right
and clearly inflation will continue to
rise and even stagflation will continue
to rise across the european union
including poland
uh the immense amount of migration that
we see right now and refugees and
displaced people
can also cause a certain concern among
you know popular
constituencies in poland if it lasts
longer than just two or three months
right and so there is a certain reason
to think that in 2023 in fall when
election happened platformer may be in a
very challenging position that the
ground for support of populism and
support of province broadcast can be
still substantial so what have you
learned since the last elections either
parliamentary or presidential that you
will adopt in your new strategy for your
party and journey for liberal minded
forces in poland in order to change the
balance of power in 2023 gotcha two more
questions
so hello
my name is miho and i have a question
about more of a developmental part of
the energy security architecture that
you mentioned so essentially there's
quite a lot of talk about the accession
of ukraine into the eu it's still
quite a far road ahead
especially for the ukrainians
and like as for russia it's pretty much
implementing a morgantown plan 2.0 in
which essentially all the western firms
are withdrawing from russia
uh which which is
studied
at the o by my
uh professor solinfeld and his team and
essentially
we see that the security infrastructure
in europe should be
and the developmental part of the
security infrastructure in europe should
be emphasized here so how do you see the
chances for ukraine to join the eu and
the future of
of of age to potentially
to to ukraine after war and maybe
potentially democratic russia
and third question yeah um thank you for
taking the question and for your time
for coming out here my name is dmitry um
my question is you already started to
touch upon the
um the previous refugee crisis and in
your opening remarks you mentioned this
idea
of building
for you know building forward so you
talked about the energy infrastructure
and you talked about
independence etc and being prepared
so will
poland be prepared and will europe
create um
an infrastructure system for the next
refugee crisis so you mentioned uh you
know certain dissatisfaction with
numbers between 7 000 and 50 000 well
are those numbers now out the door
because experience proves to us that
that we can you know we can handle much
more than that and so when the next
crisis comes and it's not from
ukraine but it's again from the more
let's say
common places where these crises occur
um will europe be able to receive these
uh refugees and of course with that kind
of going to my friend maximus's question
with um
the populist governments not just the
polish one looking to score uh points on
this
uh a lot of the
points that have been uh used you know
as criticism for for peace right that um
you know the lgbtq rights women's rights
judicial reform et cetera
that that those topics have kind of
become buried and i think that's that's
probably uh um to a great you know
they're very happy about that so how do
we
you know or what is uh your plan is you
are a member of the opposition party um
to see that those those points remain
salient and make sure that europe is
prepared and is welcoming
to
um people who happen to not be europeans
next time gotcha
okay so first of all when it comes to
the uh uh european perspective for
ukraine i mean that's a very good
question because i think that that
things have uh changed in in uh
in the heads of a lot of european
politicians so for the first time
because you know they were telling us
it's impossible you know ukraine moldova
not now and and you've seen the progress
of the negotiations with the balkan
states and so on and so forth so now
it's the moment that's the window of
opportunity to speed it up of course you
know it took us
more than a decade from the first
declaration to actually enter the
european union from from the association
agreement to to to to the
to the membership more than 13 years but
of course now is the moment to to drive
that point home and to
to uh to uh start the process
but again you know you
you know how for how long turkey has
been negotiating membership with the
european union from at least 1968.
so
but now's the moment and that's my
answer and now we should be driving it
as
and keeping it on the agenda of of the
european union because
because that's the only way forward and
by the way the russians even said nato
no european union okay
by the way you know the membership in
the european union would be
much more
maybe
maybe not much more but as
serious a guarantee to the ukrainians
that they will remain a part of the west
as
as as anything else
when it comes to what you said about
refugees i i don't think that europe
will ever be ready in a sense that you
know welcoming and so on this is the
hottest
topic ever
the hot button issue look at the united
states and so on and so forth
we are better prepared than we used to
be because finally we have a lot of
instruments you know we have the
instruments for
helping in the third countries we have
instruments when it comes to relocating
uh
immigrants within dealing with secondary
movements uh we have european border
guards
we've we've done quite a lot of things
in order to prepare ourselves okay for
different type of crises we have
we we have all of those readmission
agreements
uh finally we have one migration policy
in europe because it used to be
completely fragmented but are we
prepared you know if we're going to have
millions and millions of additional
refugees of course it always is going to
be a political problem and it is
politically incorrect to say but you
know in a polish case these guys look
like us they speak a very similar
language there's this cultural affinity
and they fight for our freedom so of
course it is easier to accept that than
to accept someone else and of course it
is very difficult to wage a a populist
fight against it because no one would
believe in it you know and even the
populist realized that so
so so so so i mean unfortunately
i don't think that we were ever be
politically prepared for that but of
course a lot is changing in in people's
mentality because they see that 7000
it's not a problem right
then
and of course the non-ukrainians
i said that in my speech you know this
is a
hot issue for for the government what to
do with them and of course there are
questions of integration i mean not now
everyone is saying you know poland did a
great job but in a month or two or three
or four if they if if no one
help us out we will have a backlash and
that there are questions if there is no
strategy what should i do with 120 000
kids you know i cannot accept them all
to our schools right and then there is a
question of integration and then there
is a question you know
how do we envisage the future it's
hellishly complicated and by the way if
we don't do anything about climate
change we're going to have hundreds of
millions of people on the move
so that's again this is a moment to
drive that point home
now about polish situation
well i i i could tell you i i draw one
very important conclusion and here i
differ from some of my colleagues
because i think that we need to be
to build a bigger tent
you know i i would submit to you that
we're not going to win an election
without political parties and of course
my own civil platform is a linchpin of
it and is is the most important right
because it's it's it's it it is the most
serious it is the most
uh the most experienced it has good
people prepared to govern and so on but
a lot of people especially young people
dislike
mainstream parties so we need to do
something about it look at peace and
look at the populist they're they
as we say in polish they're playing on
different pianos at the same time okay
so they
they've
strengthened the party but they were
building foundations they were building
discussion clubs they were building
internet platforms they were doing
grassroot movements you know they were
doing everything
and some of my colleagues say platform
platform platform i love it i say we can
chant together but i told them no we
also need to add on we need to
consolidate the local mayors
and that's what we did we have an
association movement that we've that
i've initiated of local mayors many most
of them are independent but we stick
together because if we don't they will
be either threatened by peace or both by
peace
or they will simply stop engaging in
national politics right and this is
again coming from my presidential
campaign because in many places
i was there and the local leader was
with me and that's why my result was so
so good
i'm going to give you one example from
eastern southern poland and why we why i
lost the election first of all you know
there was no
even playing field you know but one of
the one of the reasons is that in our
strongholds we get 70 percent
and peace gets 30 in the big cities in
their strongholds in the eastern rural
areas there's in in in
in many counties i got 10 or 15
and duda got the president of poland
good 85 or 90 percent there's one county
in podca
where there is a where there is a mayor
who used to be a cop in warsaw
and he went and he said to to to the
priests i mean if you keep on
preaching politics from the pulpit
you're not going to help renovate
the church
stop it
okay you keep on
talking about saskowski it was because
of warsaw that after the flood you know
warsaw as a sign of solidarity they
paved the roads
and they help us out
and don't believe
this this
those those lies about him trying to
change the way we live i know him he has
a respect for tradition and so on and so
forth in this county i got 35
okay impossible to win but 35 not 10 or
15.
and when i go there they tell me i mean
if you come in your political hat it's
going to be difficult if you come as a
mayor great
no problem
and thirdly we've done a campus poland
initiative where we invited thousands
people young people from all over poland
socially active
and for a week we were talking about the
topics that they wanted to talk about
so they wanted to talk talk about
women's rights global warming artificial
intelligence and so on and we were
talking about i was there for a week
many of them were afraid that we were
going to indoctrinate them no it was an
open debate and many of my colleagues
were there we invited politicians we
invited experts we invited rock stars we
were having concerts we were having
sports activities and we've created an
alternative grassroot movement and a
network which works and now when i go to
port carpaccia
okay i can of course i'm meeting with
platformer
but that's not enough because they're
convinced people but i'm meeting with
the local leaders and meeting with the
young people
and they're local so they tell me
those guys are they will vote for peace
forever you can of course talk to them
but
be aware you know these guys are yours
so say hi but don't spend time because
you know there are platformer guys
those are the guys you need to be
convincing you know
so so that's so what i'm saying is that
i am absolutely convinced that
you know the opposition parties first of
all we all have to be more mature and we
have to collaborate and start
trusting each other that's very
important
but we have to build a bigger tent and
and do what other what populace are
doing
you know try to to to reach out and and
talk to the people who are not convinced
and by the way the campus thing you know
eighty percent of the people had nothing
to do with politics
they were political in the sense that
they were active but they were not party
political many of them
hate my party
some of them not many but some hate me
but they were there and we had
balzerovich there you know the the
founder of the the of of the shock
therapy
for half of the young kids he was a hero
he was god for half of them he was devil
incarnate
because they were you know from the left
you should see you should have seen the
discussion
i mean how how how how hot it was and
ellen balceros was you know like this
because he's god at his university and i
think he was asking difficult questions
and guess what they were pushing
politicians who are very cautious some
of my friends
to be much more
you know courageous because they were
pushed so much and and and politicians
are not that used to
having an open room and having you know
hundreds of questions and then they need
to to answer them you know so i mean
that's my only answer
talk to the unconvinced do the grass
movement
be with the people and that's that's
that's a lesson from being a mayor
because you you're just accountable you
walk the streets and then all the time
you were you're asked questions
no other question no other no other
answer but i i remain hopeful
do you have time for another question
okay um yes my name is dudata i applaud
you and as part of being polish i i know
police have the refugees a lot my
question for you as a mayor of orso
i know that
sometimes
um started saying comes april first they
will stop helping
the big expo places to um have places
for ukraine refugees and they decrease
amount
per day how much they spend on an
ukraine refugee i know that the good
weather is coming a lot of motels hotels
are going to need the tourist money
what is the immediate plan for work so
you as a president and for other cities
involving to help the refugees and
relocate them somewhere else
great
two more questions and
mr president
i would like to know from uh
your perspective
how uh
the whole uh crisis i mean coming coming
back to you
your question also
how this crisis will actually impact
uh the budget
of warsaw and what is your plan
uh what are the countermeasures that you
would like to take
given the
non-cooperative government that we have
wonderful both great questions
thank you coming mayor ms victor uh as
rally noticed in your lecture the
current government polish government has
experienced an incredible turnaround in
its public image and international
standings in just about two months
so from an outlier marred by full of law
issues abuse of gay and women rights
challenging international
investors in your property rights and a
very damaging reaction to the us
presidential election 2020 they became a
strategic partner of brussels and
washington celebrated for a generous and
courageous response to the current
crisis
all that in just months
my question is do you ask one of the
leaders of the publisher position that
has been fighting those abuses for the
last seven years
feel like the government is getting a
pass from the west has been that of the
hook
my job is that they don't
uh well i mean you know of course the
most important thing is that we resolve
a problem and i'm i'm i'm collaborating
with this government you know and and
and when it's below the radar sometimes
it's even a good cooperation okay but of
course they're you know pushing most of
the responsibility our way and and they
promised the money and it's going to be
like with the pandemic that at the
beginning we were collaborating and then
they were pushing all the responsibility
our way and they were taking money away
from us
and one day they were saying
i'm responsible for 11 hospitals one
hospital needs to be covered okay fine
and then they say no no no no all of
your hospitals need to have a covered
ward okay
okay and then they suddenly set up you
know a hospital at a national stadium
and they pay all the doctors three times
more so all the dogs start working there
and they don't have enough equipment so
when there's a serious case all of those
guys come to me okay that's that's a
lack of strategy and that's what i'm
afraid is going to happen this time
around so i cannot i don't have my own
relocation strategy because we need a
relocation
strategy not not only on a national
level but on the european level okay and
i am telling the government exactly what
what you've just told us and i'm telling
all my friends in the european union and
america that this is going to end we
cannot do it indefinitely that's why we
need to have a relocation scheme that's
why we might
need
more reception centers
created by the un agency who know best
how to do it we don't have to invent a
wheel we have all of those guys
on the ground but they're just not
authorized to to work because there's no
coordination and there's no call for
help there's no memorandum of
understanding between the central
government and them and that's what we
need because you know of course we are
you know we are
retrofitting office spaces i decided to
keep those tents even though now we
don't have an influx of refugees open
to prepare for a second wave but you
know what can i do i can prepare for 10
000 people 15 000 people i cannot
prepare for another for another hundred
thousand and what if many people will
simply say okay i cannot accept
ukrainians anymore at my home okay of
course there's a problem with those
hotels that you've mentioned and so on
that's why we need strategy that's why
we need help from from the european
union financial help and and relocation
strategy okay
now when it comes to the government
washing their hands and i mean first of
all
we need to keep the pressure on those
guys also also for for security reasons
because we need to be a strong democracy
and i know and that's you know i told
that to president biden when i had a
chance i told that to secretary blinken
and they know it i've told that
on the hill i'm telling that to all my
european friends
so that they need to
remember that and i also give them
ready-made recipes i tell them listen
if you are connecting your money with
rule of law you put me in a
schizophrenic situation
because i cannot i i cannot say that i i
want the money to be i don't want the
money to be blocked
see i'm so used to propaganda that i
don't even say the sentence which can be
cut out out of context so
i don't want the the the money to to to
be blocked of course and and frozen
but
they need to be tough on the government
so i tell them so give a bit of money to
us directly
to the local governments it's as easy as
that it's a win-win populist do not win
cities
make a huge program that takes away
diesel-powered buses from the streets of
european cities and give them directly
to the cities which are ambitious by the
way warsaw was just announced one of the
hundred
green cities in europe we
we are in it okay again a bit of direct
financing that's what i was fighting for
for for the past three years so that you
know there are solutions and that's what
i'm telling our american friends
most of them understand it but many of
them especially in europe would want to
use it as a pretext because they are fed
up with with with
with you know having to
ask the peace government about it
but it's the job of ours the job of of
of of of also public opinion to keep on
pushing
and to explain and that's like
to my american friends that's what i'm
saying i'm not telling them values
values values because you know
although
ukrainians are actually dying for those
values now
they're dying exactly for the values
that that there are that are undermined
in some of our countries
but
i tell them that they they need a strong
ally they need a credible ally they need
a democratic ally they they cannot
afford no one can afford poland to be
now a weak democracy so this is an
incredibly important issue and that's
why this this pressure needs to be kept
up and and and that's why it is so so so
so so important and and and hopefully i
mean this is not going to uh and you
know most of my colleagues
most of my interlocutors understand that
and there hasn't been honestly there
hasn't been such a strong effect of you
know rallying the flag
as some people expected so that gives us
hope that at the end of the day
uh people
pose when it comes to elections that
they will take to write
the right decisions okay and that they
will
not forget about what this government
was doing
okay and it's also of course our job to
to make sure that that happens okay
did i omit any uh question i think i've
answered yours yes
okay i think i addressed all the
questions
yeah guys yeah i think
yes
you know it's up to you i mean you are i
can i can still answer them
there are surely two uh so like
one i will summarize because people are
sure shoot
so first question uh regarding
uh lgbtqia plus
community rights in poland
and how you see
their future
in polish society
regarding current events and within the
internal policies of poland and the
second is uh more grounded to
what's going on right now that
that many uh the suggestion is that many
polish people
are going to be affected by part of of
the gas
and
who that will be and what will be the
repercussions
last question
i have a question that might be a
broader zoomed out question
um back to the point that you've been
really stressing about the need for
strategy
so um
if we talk about european strategy in
the wake of the war in ukraine or well
it's not really in the way because there
were still going on
um
and i would love to get your thoughts
about broader geopolitical dimensions of
strategy
that is european union's policy or
strategy on relations with russia
what are
key components of that strategy that you
would like to see in place that's one
and i'm asking that in addition to
weaning uh
european countries meaning themselves
about fossil fuels and especially
russian fossil fuels so what are some of
the other
important uh components of such a
european strategy
and i guess the second question is um
who should be deciding it and how should
this strategy be decide decided
can you think of what according to you
would be a good mechanism of arriving
at a viable and productive european
strategy
uh of course ideally one that is free
from hungarian veto and you know things
like that
well i mean
there is no other place to to to make a
strategy by the european council where
all the heads
heads uh uh of governments meet and
that's the place to establish a strategy
according to the treaties and of course
there just needs to be enough pressure
on the hungarians and all the others to
to
not to water water down this is the most
important thing and of course the
important thing is to keep up sanctions
in place to strengthen europe when it
comes to its defense uh and security
dimension
to yes to make europe independent of of
fossil fuels and speed up the transition
uh
and also to do it in a way which is
which is smart
to offer a serious perspective to
ukrainian and to moldova when it comes
to to to to the membership of the
european union at least those two
countries but but speed up uh
the accession and and of course
to adopt
a common policy when it comes to to uh
displace people and have a relocation
scheme because this is immensely uh
immensely important
uh so
most of the uh of the elements of the of
of of the strategy are are there it's
now just a question to uh
to to to to get them together and to put
them together and and not to
to allow anyone to water it down as
simple as that
or as difficult as that
and now yeah
when you say stronger military do you
mean within the structures of nato or
outside both i mean we have we have the
structures ready because we do not want
to duplicate nato and after the wars of
summit we know how to strengthen nato
but also strengthen the european
dimension which is which is part of the
same system as a second leg there is no
no talk about the competition but for
example you know all the things that now
we're doing like providing
lethal weapons i mean it was unthinkable
a few a few months ago that europe could
do it now it's just a question of better
coordinating it
and and of course a part of that
strategy also it's not only you the
european union strategy but nato
strategy for example
you know we do not do rotating bases but
permanent nato bases in in in poland or
in romania or in the baltic states
because of course there is also security
dimension to it
now when it comes to uh to gas and and
we are for now we are prepared
also because of of of most of the things
that we've done under the energy union
but of course that needs uh the
resilience of the system and of our
allies which needs providing us with gas
and of course uh we need to prepare for
for the more difficult
uh months and we need european
solidarity it was announced but now we
need to put it in practice and also the
international solidarity we can we are
finishing the the connections with the
norwegian fields but of course we can
import gas from the us and so on and so
forth i think that president biden just
yesterday indicated referenced it so
let's hope that that will go into that
direction and again
you know at the end of the day it is
pieces governing in poland
so and of course we have inflation
everywhere but
more so in poland and this is because of
some crazy decisions of the central bank
which is in in in in in in the hands of
the of the peace uh crony and and of
course we need to also explain to the
people that most of the decisions
were all of the decisions were taken by
peace and that that they need to be hold
held accountable at
the at the uh
uh
elections that are coming
and the last thing uh last but not least
the lgbtq community
i mean
they you know these guys the peace guys
the government the populist government
was trying to they always need to have
an enemy
and i think that they've used because of
my presidential campaign they've used
all kinds of arguments they could
in order to attack me to attack the lgbt
community and i think that they they
went so far that they just ridiculed
themselves
i'm just going to give you one example
because not all of you have followed the
polish politics i've signed the lg lgbt
charter as the first mayor
for now the only mayor in poland to help
out the lgbt community and we've said
that in this document it says that we're
going to use the w.h.o standards world
health organization as a benchmark
what the
peace propaganda did they took a booklet
from who written by experts for teachers
explaining
how children develop that they get
interested in their bodies when they're
eight and ten they start masturbating
with their twelve and so on and for
three weeks they've unleashed this
campaign that i want to teach
masturbation to
to to children at school
and that was like you know the key the
key argument that they had throughout
the campaign
and of course everyone in warsaw and
poznan and krakow was laughing like you
are laughing but in the rural areas they
were not laughing
you know but they they've went so far
that that now when i go and travel
around poland and i talk to people they
know that it that it's just it's just
not true
okay
so of course we will keep on defending
all the minorities and by the way you
know i'm not a crazy leftist as they try
to portray me i'm just this is my job
as a mayor you know if someone gets by
and it's successful my job is not to
meddle
because they get by and if i have people
who have problems or they're
marginalized or attacked
my job is to help them because i'm a
mayor you know and it doesn't matter
whether they're senior citizens uh
people with disabilities lgbt minorities
all kinds of minorities you know we are
there to help and that should be no
that's a normal standard of a democratic
country
and i think that we were driving that
point home all the time
and i hope that we are in a different
place when it comes i mean it will be
very difficult again to unleash this
campaign people have heard all the
arguments and they look around and you
know
nothing changed
i still have two kids
same wife and a dog and a parrot
[Laughter]
you know and our way of life is not
threatened because we've signed an lgbt
child and when we say that you know
that we should be protecting everyone's
rights and that that's that's the
foundations of the democratic society
so i think that and many people say that
you know i lost the election because of
that and so on and so forth but at least
you know people saw that there are
politicians in poland who do
things that they believe in
and
and and and that's worthwhile in itself
and we've opened doors to start
discussing subjects that maybe were
taboo for a while by the way not easy
anywhere
when was the uh when was the uh
judgment of the supreme court of the
united states on same-sex marriages 2015
it wasn't 50 years ago
and don't get me started
okay
so i mean you know it's not that we're
barbarians or we don't understand that
sometimes we're here you know we just
need people with guts to start debating
these things
and explaining to people that that that
that you know this is this is what we
should be doing this is the right thing
to do
and on top of that explaining that there
is no ideology
there are just people and no ideology
and that no one threatens our way of
life
look at the european union i mean you
know we collaborate
we
build the community together and it
strengthens our national identity it
doesn't weaken it
and it strengthens not only the french
identity but also the
identity
and provencal identity also kashubian
identity in poland
that's what we should be doing
and do you see i don't know italians
from florence like fretting about it or
i'm going to lose my florence identity i
will start speaking i don't know with a
roman accent because of the european
union no
okay
i'm i'm not losing my polish identity
i'm not losing my my warsaw identity
because i'm also european you know and
we need to drive that point home
okay and i think that either you have
guts to start these debates or you don't
but but i hope that that that that we've
started these debates in poland now we
just need to hold this
government accountable okay
and here i'm finishing we need to keep
the pressure up
okay because if i see
that
in a ukrainian crisis one of the ngos
which got the biggest support from the
national government in poland is mr
bonkevich
crazy fascist guy who's organizing those
those those those marches around warsaw
which torch of my city and these guys
are are you know sometimes pronouncing
words which which which are simply
racist and so on and so and they got
support because they've accepted some
ukrainians and they've got millions from
the government millions of support and
then i talked to an ngo la strada who is
fighting with women trafficking and with
forced prostitution and they tell me
finally we can work and i said what
happened he said you support us but we
got this additional grant from american
donors five thousand dollars and we can
work
okay
and here i'm driving point home i mean
please go and spread the message
ngos in poland need support
okay local government needs support
volunteers need support and even if the
credit goes you know and suddenly
everyone loves duda in the united states
fine
let them love him
but help us because at the end of the
day what you see in poland it's not a
miracle
it's just solidarity and it is the civil
society it is the non-government
organizations it's the charities who do
that
and that's why we need to help them and
that's why i'm you know i'm not in a
junket but i'm trying to uh convince the
american public opinion the donors the
ngos the political foundations
uh and so on that that we all need to
get our act together
and that we should not lose focus from
the state of democracy in poland because
poland needs to be a linchpin of
european security and at the end again
and again and again ukrainians are
fighting for our freedom too for yours
too guys
and for the stability of transatlantic
alliance and for the values
that we are preaching and we're talking
about and they are dying for them and at
the end of the day remember that all the
bad guys in the world are looking
so we need to prove to them
that
we are going to be tough and united and
we are going to draw the lessons and
it's not worthwhile to start wars attack
sovereign nations attack people kill
them rape them because otherwise we're
going to end up in a situation like we
end up in warsaw and of course in
ukraine okay so so that's why we should
be spreading the message and if you tell
me will the world forget maybe but it's
our job guys yours too some of you are
polish latvian some of you are ukrainian
but many of you are american just go out
and spread the message
and come to warsaw it's not a war zone
help us out
leave a lot of money
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
you